just getting everyone in Focus here
I always say I always take requests here
hey right on good afternoon everybody
I'm Adrian Dixon BC's minister of Health
joining me today is Dr Bonnie Henry BC's
provincial Health officer and I want to
start by acknowledging the territory of
the muskrum of the Squamish and the
slave tooth we're honored to be giving
this presentation on their lands today
we're here to provide an update on what
to expect in this year's respiratory
illness season for uh for our health our
health care and our Health Care system
and it's my honor to begin by
introducing Dr Bonnie Henry to discuss
the respiratory illness season Dr
thank you and good afternoon whoa
um I just want to start as well by
acknowledging that uh coming up this
Saturday is our national day of Truth
and Reconciliation September 30th and I
encourage everyone to actively
participate in learning the truth about
the residential school system Indian
hospitals and the impacts it's had on
First Nation communities across this
entire province
and actively advancing together
in elevating true reconciliation as a
way forward for us in this country
So today we're going to talk about
protecting BC in this respiratory virus
season
see if I can make this move to actively
participate in learning the truth about
the residential school system Indian
hospitals and the impacts it's had on
First Nation communities across this
entire Province and actively advancing
together
and elevating true reconciliation as a
way forward for us in this country
So today we're going to talk about
protecting BC in this respiratory virus
season
let's see if I can make this move
okay first I want to give a sense of
what happened last year and where we are
to put this in perspective so last year
we saw the return of other respiratory
viruses like influenza and RSV amongst a
number of others and you can see on this
uh graph the green for example or
enteroviruses and rhinoviruses those are
the cold viruses and we've seen those
that persist through the summer as well
in to summarize it of what we saw last
year was that sarskoviti really was
fluctuating through the year mostly in
adults and causing more severe illness
in adults and we'll talk a bit more
about that we had a relatively early
influenza season with a sharp short
spike and it impacted children more than
we have seen in the past as well we've
had we had a relatively severe RSV
season which also affected mostly
children higher than our historical
averages
so we know that much of this is related
to the fact that we had return of Global
Travel and that these viruses circulate
with people and we move around the globe
and it's important that we recognize
that this movement of people is also
part of how we important for our
economies important for our health
important for being able to to get
together after the years that we've been
through
uh the southern hemisphere can give us
some indications of what we might expect
this year and what they saw was again
variable covid over the period of the
other respiratory virus season they also
saw influenza H1N1 and influenza B and
we're starting to see that that might be
what we would see here again those are
viruses that particularly affect
children so that's something that we'll
be looking out for and they also saw a
variable RSB season
so I want to go back in and just look a
little bit and put it in context for
what happened in BC last year so as I
said in the blue there you can see we
had an early sharp influenza Peak but if
we break it down by age we can see that
very young children are the ones most
affected so infants up to four years of
age in particular but also children in
school age children as well and with all
of these viruses we know that people
over the age of 70 have the highest risk
of having severe illness ending up in
hospital or having complications from
these viruses
so we have that U-shaped curve where
very young and older people are more
affected we also saw that covet
particularly affected older people while
there was also some increased activity
in the very young who are most at risk
people over the age of 70 were more
likely to have severe illness more
likely to end up in hospital so the
double risk that they have with these
two viruses really speaks to the
importance of the protection that we
need from the updated vaccines both for
influenza and for coven
so this slide is a little bit busy but I
want to talk to it for a minute we know
that protection from vaccines and from
infection well it wanes over time so it
decreases over time but there's two
different parts to that that is
important it never goes back to zero so
what we know from the serial prevalence
so that's that graph on the on the top
the serial prevalence that's markers in
the blood of people who have antibodies
against covet and we know that some of
these antibodies are from vaccine and
some of these antibodies can be from
infections so that's the bottom line
the the what we see is that over time
just about everybody in this province
has some protection has antibodies to
covet 19. and that's a combination of
vaccinations people having two three
four sometimes six if you're somebody
who's immune compromised and having
infections particularly we've seen those
infections markers increase since
Omicron started many of these people
particularly people who are vaccinated
didn't even know that they had an
infection with omepron because they had
protection from severe illness so that's
the thing that's important it never goes
back to zero we know we have this
cell-mediated immunity or memory
immunity and once you have vaccinations
or combinations of vaccinations and
infections that immunity is long lasting
and we're learning that now from the
studies that have been done over time we
also see that this hybrid immunity is
different in different age groups so
what does that tell us that tells us
that young people are more likely to
have had combinations of vaccination and
infections we know that people who've
had no vaccination most of them have had
some indication of infection if you're
younger but those can Wane over time so
unvaccinated people remain most at risk
for severe illness and hospitalizations
as we're heading into this next
respiratory virus season
we also see that older people are less
likely to have markers of infection and
what does that tell us that tells us
that vaccination has been really good at
protecting older people but it also
means that they don't have this hybrid
infected immunity and it's really
important that we get boosted and we get
this updated vaccine to protect us from
infection with the viruses that are
circulating right now this is also
relevant to the healthcare worker
mandate because if we look at that age
group that most health care workers are
we know that all healthcare workers in
our system right now have vaccination
most of them have multiple doses
at least two but almost everybody has
had at least one booster and we know
that that many of them also have hybrid
immunity the majority of us have hybrid
immunity from infections and exposures
to Omicron over the past year so that
gives us a really good buffer but what
we need to focus on now is this updated
vaccine that will protect us from what's
going around right now and give a extra
boost to that that long-term immunity
that we still have
so this is a um the graph of what we're
seeing right now in terms of covid
specifically for hospitalizations on the
top and critical care Admissions and
deaths so the hospitalizations are test
positive so people have a PCR test and
we know that mostly that's people who
are in hospital for other reasons and or
people who have more severe illness so
they get a test from their doctor a PCR
test
for this we we recognize as well that
test positive in hospital paper people
and people who are in hospital about 40
percent of those cases are people who
are there because of covet and we know
right now we've had a bump up in the
last few weeks because there's been a
few outbreaks and clusters and so we've
been doing a lot of testing at people in
hospital so it's a combination right now
of people who are asymptomatic people
who have been in hospital for something
else who got a Cova test that's positive
and that we need to pay attention to and
for people who actually do have covet so
those are things
um that that we follow over time and it
tells us that yeah we're starting to see
more covet in the community and I think
that's no surprise to people we're also
starting to see other viruses that cause
infections we're seeing a little bit of
influenza we have not seen much RSV yet
but those are the ones we're looking for
throughout this pandemic whole genome
sequencing has become a really important
tool that helps us understand how the
virus is changing over time and this is
something that we know all viruses
change and they mutate as they try and
um be better at infecting people and
what we've seen in sort of in big
letters there is really since early 2022
it's been various different strains of
Omicron and it's a key part of
understanding the changes and it is
relatively new technology this is the
first time ever we've been able to sort
of watch a virus change in real time so
we sometimes pay a lot of attention to
oh it's xbv 1.5 it's xpv this it's EEG
0.5 and those are the ones that we're
seeing circulate around now but really
what we want to know is is the vaccine
still going to protect us what is the
advantage of this virus over the
previous ones that were closely related
to it is it causing more severe illness
so those are the things that we were
monitoring as well right now what's
important is it has been Omicron there's
been slight changes so these are all
related to each other what we're seeing
here in British Columbia is xpb 1.16
eg.5 are the ones that was identifying
most commonly so far we've only had the
one identification of va 2.86 which is a
slightly distant cousin
but there are many many other slight
variations that are circulating around
here now as well
and the important thing is studies are
shown from the clinical trials from
Lab studies that have been done that
that the vaccine that has been developed
this new updated vaccine xbb 1.5 it's
based on that shows good protection
against all of these ones that we're
seeing circulate right now so that's
good news
I want to also say just a word about
testing so the rapid antigen tests that
are still available around in pharmacies
right now
um they still work and we've been
monitoring those to see if they pick up
these new strains as well and it is
um it is they are still helpful for
people who are isolating at home and
have milder illness it helps you know if
it's covered
but we need to remember that covet is
not the only virus that's causing people
to be sick right now
just to move on one of the other tools
that has been so helpful for us since
the pandemic started is looking at
Wastewater surveillance and what that
gives us is a sense of Trends over time
in different communities and as you know
we've expanded the Wastewater
surveillance to more areas around BC and
it helps us as a passive way of looking
at Trends so all of these are pieces of
a picture that help us understand what's
going on right now
so we are seeing gradual increases it's
still relatively low but gradual
increases across the province
what will be new over the next few weeks
you'll see is that we've been able to
the scientists and clinicians at the
bccdc have been working hard to validate
tests for other respiratory viruses that
we can check in Wastewater as well so it
is kind of exciting that we're doing
this it's new in Canada and we'll be
looking for influenza A but also for RSV
and we don't know a lot about RSV and
what strains circulate and how it
changes over time and why some years we
have more severe Seasons than others so
all of these will be available in the
bccdc dashboard that you'll be able to
to follow over time as well
the other addition that we're adding
that's new this year on the dashboard is
emergency department visits for what we
call the syndrome of respiratory illness
so it's how many people are presenting
to an emergency department with a cough
and a fever and other signs of
respiratory illness that are indicative
of what's going on in the community so
it's a syndrome we call it syndromic
surveillance and you'll be able to
follow that over time and what we're
seeing right now in this picture is that
we're starting to see a slight increase
this will also be available on the new
dashboard so just to put this up we've
been reporting monthly over the summer
when when rates of respiratory illnesses
we're low across the province and now as
things are ramping up and we know that
we traditionally see more respiratory
illnesses as we go into this season
we'll be increasing the frequency and so
starting October 5th these will be
available in the bccdc website on a
weekly basis and you'll be able to look
at
all of the covid-19 updates but also the
respiratory disease updates all together
on that web page so that's important
that's what will help us know where
we're going and the trajectories over
time
so what else do we need to do to prepare
as we go into the fall
it's really going back to what we all
know and sometimes maybe a bit tired of
but the healthy habits that keep us from
getting sick ourselves and also keep us
from passing it on to others
particularly to our loved ones and
others in our community so we know that
influenza covid RSV enteroviruses
adenoviruses all of those things that
cause respiratory illnesses tend to come
back as we go into the fall and winter
really important is staying up to date
on both influenza and covet vaccines and
we'll talk a minute about what we have
available for those
staying home if you have a cough and a
fever those are signs that you're
infectious to others and you need to
stay away
particularly staying away from people
who are more vulnerable so if you're not
feeling well yourself even if it's mild
don't go visit somebody in a long-term
care postpone that visit if you can or
take precautions to make sure you're not
going to expose somebody who might be
more at risk
cleaning your hands regularly covering
your coughs and sneezes even wearing a
mask if you have mild symptoms or if
you're recovering and you're going to be
in an indoor space with people who might
be more at risk
I do want to say a minute or about
testing I mentioned that the rapid
antigen test that you can get still work
and you they're important to use they
can tell you if you have covet but they
won't tell you if you have influenza or
one of those other viruses
so even if it's negative it's important
to stay home and stay away from others
and tell your symptoms have resolved and
particularly until fever has resolved
if you are somebody who's higher risk or
you have more severe symptoms than you
should see your health care provider and
in that case you'll likely get a PCR
test and as we did last year all of the
PCR tests go to the lab they're tested
for five viruses so it's called a
multiplex test so it tests for influenza
A influenza B for covid for RSV and for
another common virus that can cause some
severe illness as well para influenza
and that's important if you are somebody
who's at higher risk you can have access
to antivirals that can help treat
influenza and to medications like
paxilovid for covid
so the updated covid-19 vaccines
are are available they're just starting
to come into the province now
the recommendation is you get it about
six months after either your last known
infection or after your last dose but we
know that this is improves long-term
protection so you get the best longer
term protection if you wait about six
months
but we also know that this one is
tailored to what we're seeing circulate
right now so it prevents infection so it
prevents us from getting the virus
causing infection in the first place
that immunity the antibodies that come
that give you that protection against
infection they increase and these are
questions that I've been asked quite a
lot over the last little while so it's
not immediate it takes a it increases
about a week to 10 days till you get
that maximum protection and what we're
learning is that after each dose that
maximum protection against infection can
last for two to three months so we want
you to get the vaccine and that's the
timing we want you to have that best
protection during the period of time
when the risk is greatest the other
thing though is that cell-mediated
immunity that memory immunity and it
gets a boost from this vaccine as well
and that lasts quite a bit longer
so we know that these are both mRNA
vaccines oh yes and uh the big news
today is that the Pfizer common
komarnati that Omicron vaccine was
approved for use by Health Canada this
morning so we have the two MRI mRNA
vaccines that have been approved by
Health Canada and that will be rolling
out in the next few days and weeks here
everybody six months of age and these
are approved for use for people six
months of age and older and we're still
waiting for the novavax the protein
vaccine but that has been submitted to
health Canada as well
so that's the coveted vaccines in terms
of influenza vaccines we have a variety
of of injectable just to remind people
there's a nasal spray vaccine for young
people it's approved for use in two to
17 years of age and we have two vaccines
two enhanced vaccines for seniors over
65 years of age both of these vaccines
the flu ad which is an adjuventive
vaccine and the flu Zone high dose are
give added protection for seniors and
have been proven to provide added
protection for seniors so those are
available as well
our campaign will be starting as soon as
vaccine comes in and we're starting with
long-term care even this week but the
public Campaign Will really launch and
Earnest so most people will expect to
start getting invitations to get your
vaccinations started right after the
Thanksgiving weekend around October 10th
we are rolling out as I mentioned
priority groups early on and everybody
should be familiar with the
getvaccinated.gov.vc.ca you can register
make sure you you get your invitation or
the call center number Remains the Same
as well
1-833-838-2323 and I do encourage people
to get both vaccines at the same time if
you're not yet due because you've just
had a booster a recent booster for your
covid vaccine important to get your flu
vaccine and then get that one when
you're due
and there will be over 1300 pharmacies
around the province that will be
offering both vaccines and additional
capacity from public health units
just to remind people in terms of
eligibility for both vaccines they're
free for everybody in BC six months of
age and older we are going to invite
priority populations first for the
reasons that I just talked about we know
that most people who are over age 65 who
are immune compromised it's been some
time since they've had a vaccine that
gives them protection since the spring
dose and we know that most of them the
vaccines have prevented them from
getting sick with the with the virus so
they're the ones who need it first will
be also providing it to residents of
long-term care home people who are
pregnant
and infants and young children in
particular we want to make sure they're
protected against influenza because we
know that they can get severe disease
from influenza
and we'll be rolling it out to health
care workers as well as soon as it's
available
finally I just want to talk a little bit
about additional infection prevention
and control measures in healthcare
settings and so this is something that
is we had low levels of respiratory
viruses circulating through the summer
we were able to remove some of the
additional precautions that were needed
in healthcare facilities but starting
next week on October 3rd we'll go we're
going to be putting back in some of the
measures to make sure that we're doing
our best to protect people who are most
vulnerable in those settings so active
screening for symptoms you'll be asked
at the door whether you have respiratory
symptoms visited visitors who do will be
asked not to attend particularly in
long-term care we know that it's really
important to to protect our seniors and
Elders in care
healthcare workers as well we have a
process for doing self-screening for
making sure that we have return to work
guidance and know what to do with that
increased hand hygiene increased
cleaning what we call respiratory
etiquette you know making sure you cough
in your sleeve clean your hands
regularly and the ambassadors will be
back at the doors of the entrances to
healthcare facilities and to Long-Term
Care Homes to to do the active screening
make sure people have access to masks
and finally medical masking will become
a requirement again continuing medical
masking by healthcare workers visitors
contractors Volunteers in patient care
areas so really focusing on those areas
where people are at risk and that
includes all health authority hospital
clinical settings all Long-Term Care
Homes seniors Assisted Living settings
private hospitals and private mental
health facilities
we are trying to find a balance
particularly in long-term care of
finding safe times for visitors to
long-term care to have that important
face-to-face contact with their loved
one in a safe way so visitors to
long-term care must wear a medical mask
in all common areas and when
participating in any of the indoor
events that are happening but we'll be
finding opportunities for them to have
um face time with your loved ones as
well we know how important that is for
the health of residents and long-term
care homes
so that's the summary of what we're
seeing so really important get up to
date on your vaccinations expect to wear
a mask if you're in a hospital or a
health care setting in the next few
months and that's the best we can do to
protect each other and to make sure that
we can slow down and decrease minimize
the impact of these viruses on ourselves
on our communities and on our Health
Care system and I'll now turn it over to
minister Dix to talk about the Health
Care system
thank you very much Dr Henry I'm going
to talk a little bit about our
preparations for Respiratory illness
season in the Health Care system and in
particular in acute care you'll know
you've got control excellent
um you'll uh some 25 hospitals
throughout the summer we saw acute care
census meaning the number of people in
the hospital five or six hundred more
than we'd usually see in summer and this
slide speaks to that we have
approximately in September uh 350 more
than we'd ordinarily seen which is a uh
to say the least a significant number of
people for to be taken care of you'll
also note that last year on January 6 we
reached 10 280 people in acute care and
at that time we took even more measures
to address that situation to ensure that
people were able to get care safely and
so that's the circumstance where that
we're in we're seeing in our Public
Health Care system is delivering more
care treating more people doing more
surgeries more Primary Care visits more
ambulance calls and our Healthcare teams
have been extraordinarily resilient to
all of that but we we have to as you
would expect under these circumstances
continue to prepare and enhance those
services this winter and that's what we
plan to do on the next slide is a is a
little bit about that preparedness
through each wave of the covid-19
pandemic our Health Care system has
learned and adapted to meet patient
needs and we're continuing to do that
today in preparation for this
respiratory illness season Health 30s
have improved access and flow teams in
place for all large hospitals seven days
a week Focus teams of healthcare
leadership administrators and Physicians
have been established on critical care
and emergency departments to support
these Priority Services now and in the
future health authorities BC emergency
Health Services the ambulance service
and the Ministry of Health continue to
coordinate our provincial capacity
meaning daily to share situational
awareness it's a day-to-day consistent
management of the system that is seven
days a week and as a backstop to all
that this we've formalized a standard
provincial surge response plan taking
the best of our response to covet and
learning from it we'll go to slide 21.
um we continue to advance our health
human resources strategy which is key to
all this and I just want to note a
couple of things that you'll see on the
slide firstly since January and this is
just January to the present this year we
have
5221 net new nurses in British Columbia
that's net new meaning that's the
increase in the number of nurses across
the problems according to the college
and the college is also prioritizing and
prioritizing 2 800 internationally
educated nurse candidates that are
either in the province or from countries
where nurses are more easily able to
integrate from and work in BC in
addition to that we have this year so
far at the College of Physicians and
surgeons registered 524 more
internationally educated medical
graduates that's in the first eight
months of this year of the 2023 year put
that in context in all of 2022 which
itself was a record year about 400 so we
would expect that number to uh to double
in 2023 reflecting the changes that have
made to improve Pathways for
internationally educated medical
graduates and other actions like the
tripling over the next two years of the
practice ready Assessment program as of
September 28th
3729 Family Physicians are practicing
under the lfp compensation model as
transformational change that we
developed with our doctors in British
Columbia for Primary Care for family
doctors 207 Family Physicians have also
now signed you to practice contracts
these are new doctors in British
Columbia to provide family medicine and
196 nurse practitioners are on contract
to provide Primary Care in addition our
hcap program has been talking about
long-term care
6546 Health Care assistants have been
hired through the health careers Access
program since its deception since it's
exception this is inclusive of the 979
that have been hired this year in
addition of course thousands of
healthcare workers have been hired in
long-term care to support infection
control go to the next slide
and so
um what we've seen in addition to that
is other programs designed to assist
this response continuing response to to
the healthcare needs of British
Columbians go Health BC the emergency
Health provider registry and the new
provincial emergency department
physician Locum pool are three
initiatives that will help meet demand
this fall and winter
there are over 73 000 hours of nursing
support to 23 communities provided by go
Health BC the provincial travel resource
program that's operated by Northern
Health we are also doing a refresh of
the emergency Health provider registry
currently there are 6113 recent
registrants including 403 Physicians and
3233 nurses we also have 134 Physicians
registered with the the emergency
department locom pool which will help
with keeping Community emergency
departments open the next slide
and obviously responding to respiratory
illness season is not just a matter of
hospitals we've discussed Primary Care
as emergency departments and hospitals
are not always the best places to do to
for patients to be Health authorities
are readying their hospitals and they
are ensuring that access to care in the
community is in place as our linkages to
community supports to people
so that they don't have to go to an
emergency department if they don't need
to everyone who needs to go to an
emergency department of course every day
should go these actions including
include expanding the capacity of urgent
and Primary Care Centers and working
with bchs to make this an alternative
for some patients
the next slide
um and now I just want to turn and
discuss a little bit about Beds which I
discussed a little bit earlier in terms
of our uh in terms of our health care
System just to say that
um that obviously this has been uh is a
significant focus and has been when we
reached we took as you know uh in
January the 20th 23 this year and
previous year significant action to
support and to address Healthcare beds
in BC our historical uh in the pandemic
in fact I would say has required us to
examine every facet of our health care
System ensure we know precisely what
assets we have that we could use and in
some cases that we need more of
sometimes it represented an inventory or
we talk about PPE often in response to
the covid-19 pandemic other times
supplies such as that but it was always
about ensuring we had the latest most
accurate information in our surgical
renewal commitment for example we did an
extensive review of surgery weightless
that brought significant new accuracy to
those lists and as you know
extraordinarily during a pandemic we've
done record numbers of surgeries and in
the month of August
thousands more surgeries than we did in
the August prior to the pandemic and so
we've now we've done this same process
with hospital beds I can tell you that
we've done that extensive work over the
summer to prepare for Respiratory
illness season our historical base bed
count in BC as you've heard me say many
times is
9202 on top of that it during the
pandemic we added we had 2
353 surge beds that we had access to as
well
we are now resetting the new base bed
count to
9880 beds to achieve this health
authorities have identified which beds
could be regularized or clinically
equipped and are use appropriate the
benefit of regularization means Stafford
no longer in temporary Alliance the
regular positions are created that
appropriate support services are hired
and that overtime can potentially be
reduced all of which will lead to more
patients getting safer care with the
right level of wraparound services in
addition Health authorities that can
have confirmed that that we will add on
top of that the capacity for 1500 surge
Beds which if needed could be activated
in the fall and winter
and so that's the that's where we stand
now I think the message today is
um is pretty clear we need and we want
everyone when they're they're invited to
do so to get vaccinated it's important
for influenza it's important for
covid-19 and Dr Henry has laid out in
detail the reasons for that we need to
use our covet sense uh that means
continuing to wash our hands and most
importantly staying home when we're sick
and wearing masks we're appropriate the
the math requirements in our hospitals
and other Healthcare settings are there
to protect those who are in those
circumstances both those working and
obviously people who are the most
vulnerable people who are in those
Healthcare settings and we have to
continue to work together it is and
continues to be a challenging time but
we know in this year of the covid-19
pandemic this fourth year we know what
to do we know these things we know we
need to get vaccinated we know we need
to wash our hands we know we need to
wear masks we know what to do and what
we need to remind ourselves of during
this season when we're going to see more
respiratory illness in the community to
continue to take those actions that we
need to do and together we can respond
effectively to what continues to be a
challenge for all of us I want to thank
everyone who works in healthcare
everyone who works in healthcare from
the healthcare assistants who have done
an exemplary job in response to the the
challenge of providing long-term care
services the health care workers who
Moved who helped move a record number of
people in long-term care during the
Wildfire season yet another challenge
they faced and performed in an exemplary
way I want to particularly highlight the
work of BC emergency Health Services in
our ambulance paramedics in that regard
everybody is working hard and we have to
continue though to work together and we
need everyone to be part of that so that
means get vaccinated and use our code
sense thanks very much and I'm going to
invite Dr Henry back to the podium for
questions
when now we'll go to questions as
mentioned previously if you'd like to
ask a question please press star one at
any time and you'll be placed into the
queue a reminder to please unmute your
phone as you will not be audible until
your name is called the first question
is from Rob buffin CTV Rob go ahead
oh hi thanks for taking my question I
guess my first question would be for Dr
Henry I'm just wondering we've heard as
I understand it about 80 of BT residents
have now had covid
um this uh situation has gone on for
many years my question is are you
concerned that uptake on covet vaccines
especially because people know the virus
causes less severe symptoms for many now
uptake is going to be much lower than
you would like and what do you think
uptake will be
I hope that people will recognize that
this is an important step it's been a
long time since most of us have had an
updated vaccine and for those who've had
covid and recognized it over the summer
it's not a pleasant infection to have
and there's still that risk of of
developing long-term symptoms so this is
the best protection that we have that
will keep us from getting sick during
this next few months and continue to
boost that protection we have for
long-term protection against severe
disease you know I think about the the
U.S is marketing it as these vaccines
like we see with influenza these
vaccines go from Wild to mild they're
really important in helping make sure
that we're not going to be out of
commission if we're young and healthy
that we're able to continue to go to
school to continue to go to work for
healthcare workers for us to be able to
make sure we're not taking it home from
work that we're staying well ourselves
so it is important vaccine it's an
updated vaccine this year that's going
to protect you from what we're seeing
right now
Rob do you have a follow-up
I do I just want to confirm and clarify
that I understand correctly that masks
will indeed be mandatory in the various
Healthcare settings that you'd set out
for the people who are required to wear
them it's not a recommendation but it is
mandatory and I'm also wondering
you know there's groups like protect
your Province who have called for masks
and places like schools as we get back
into this season
um why not why not require masks to be
worn in schools as well but I do really
want that clarification on whether masks
are mandatory it is a requirement yes
they are mandatory in those settings in
healthcare settings and we've said this
all along you know there's different
risks in different settings and we know
that people who are most vulnerable
elders and seniors in long-term care
people are in hospital for a variety of
reasons many of whom are immune
compromised or older they're the people
who need this protection the most that's
where it makes the most difference in
terms of having these layers of
protection we know that all healthcare
workers are vaccinated many the majority
have a hybrid immunity as well we're
getting to step up and get the the
additional protection from this new
vaccine the new vaccines influenza is
also important and so it makes it's
really important that we add that extra
layer for people who are going in and
out of of these most high risk settings
we know that schools have a variety of
different
parameters schools are not the same as a
hospital the most important thing we
have in schools is that stay home when
they're sick that we have a Provisions
for that that we've looked at
ventilation that we have a known
population it's not a bunch of different
people coming and going like we see in
an acute care facility for example so
there's
um there is other measures in place that
protect schools and we've seen that
schools are a very safe place for
children doesn't mean that children
don't get respiratory viruses of course
they do we know that we've seen that
every year prior to the pandemic and now
we have another one that's in the mix
and that's the SARS cov2 virus so we
need to pay attention to all of the the
things that we would normally do and
need to think about it in terms of all
of the respiratory viruses that are out
there
our next question is from Chuck Chang
the Canadian press
foreign
in the next month or so or are we
talking about anything before the end of
the year and also what does that
actually physically look like are you
gonna actually physically be increasing
the space within the hospitals are you
going to be building more spaces or you
know how how is just trying to get a
clarification on how that's going to
work the key part about increasing the
bed base about Staffing and about how we
treat beds in the Health Care System
I've said many times at these briefings
that we had approximately uh 9 200 base
acute care beds and 2300 surge beds and
what we've done is established the beds
that have the proper equipment that are
in place and raise the number and build
we're going to build regular Staffing
around them the key to those beds is not
the space itself we are of course
building hospitals as you know around BC
see but but how we treat the beds how we
fund the beds how we support the beds
and how we staff the beds and clearly
we're in a period where we've gone from
a time when 9 200 base pass might be
sufficient with time now when we need to
increase that number of beds and that's
what we're doing so really it's about
regularizing those beds and Staffing
them on a regular basis we of course
staff surge beds now and we meet the
test that that comes but this is an
improvement for staff and Improvement
for Recruitment and it reflects in our
actions and how we organize the Health
Care System how it it reflects that in
terms of our response so if we're seeing
as we have this week 99 700 people in in
acute care getting care in BC
regularizing 9880 beds makes sense and
that will happen in in October
Chuck do you have a follow-up
yes thank you um also for the minister
you mentioned earlier in the summer that
you know we're seeing that the process
all record number of surgeries and
things of that nature that really put
the emergency room uh staff and the
workers in in these settings really
under stress and you were worried about
them not getting uh the usual downtime
to somewhat recover before the
respiratory season begins um I was
wondering given the updated attitude
regarding the the type of infections
that you may see not only from covet but
also from flu are you confident in the
the current Staffing and the the
system's ability to handle this if we
see another Spike or if you see another
sort of rush that perhaps is higher than
what the what the problem is projecting
so we prepared for Respiratory illness
season and Healthcare in 2020 and 2021
and 2022 and now in 2023 and we've built
on uh what we've learned in those times
and I think our Healthcare staff have
dealt with it let's be clear every year
even prior to covet the busiest months
for our hospitals were during
respiratory illness season the point I
was making this summer was that we
continued to see even in summer when
there typically was fewer people in
health in in hospitals in our senses
we're continuing to see High Health Care
settings and that
does isn't a significant Demand on
health care workers from the whole
Healthcare Community on surgeries I
think it's a different situation we as
you remember in March of 2020 we
implemented the surgical renewal program
which meant a very significant training
and adding of anesthesiologists of uh of
uh Pro of medical device Pro assisting
technicians of operating room nurses we
raise the level of and the hours of
surgery we've done in British Columbia
such that in the period that we reported
on on surgical renewal last week which
is from April 1st through to August we
had done had 13
000 more surgical hours operating room
hours in British Columbia it's an
extraordinary success in August we
shattered previous records in terms of
numbers of surgeries but let's be clear
the Health Care system is delivering on
all those levels surgical renewal those
shows and demonstrates what planning and
a sustained strategy does it increased
our capacity it increased the number of
people working in surgery it increased
the number of surgeries across surgical
categories and that's the kind of
planning we need to do I think part of
the problem in the past in healthcare in
British Columbia prior to my time in
this position was a tendency to respond
to difficult Problems by short-term
funding and then that funding goes away
we change the base with surgical renewal
as we did in funding long-term care
hours as we've done in Primary Care such
that we're building out a system year
into year with permanent funding and a
permanent change in the base so yes it's
stressful when we do more and more
surgeries but it also means waiting
times and our performance compared to
other jurisdictions there's another
report today showing us number two
in an important area of surgery behind
Pei over the last number of years I
think all of that shows and has proven
itself and it's not a credit to me it's
a credit to our doctors and nurses and
healthcare workers
our next question is from Richard zusman
Global News Richard
uh Dr Henry what is a health care
setting when it comes to this mask
mandate does this include family doctors
offices dentist's office chiropractors
and you worried at all about conflict uh
between people who have gotten used to
not wearing a mask now being told uh in
some areas they have to put a mask back
on yeah so this is all of the the
healthcare settings that are health
authority owned and operated and run as
well as Long-Term Care Homes across the
board we don't have directives that
affect Physicians and dentists and
private practitioners in the community
we do provide guidance and and
recommendations to them and I I know
from my own experience that most
dentists office have never stopped
wearing masks and they wear them as a
part of routine and so it does include
for example Ambulatory Care Centers that
are connected to a hospital so it would
be waiting rooms offices
where patients are so it's patient care
areas so the administrative areas where
people are or cafeteria where people are
eating it won't be mandatory in those
settings but it will be in all of the
the areas where people who are receiving
care or who residents are
Richard do you have a follow-up
are you worried at all about conflict
existing here and I also want to ask and
this could lead to conflict as well the
issue around the vaccine mandate and the
Health Care system can you explain to me
why you are not requiring health care
workers to have a full update of their
vaccines in terms of getting every
booster I understand you spoke about uh
some natural immunity and that many
workers have already received that why
not make that a requirement of their
employment that health care workers have
the full list of available coveted
vaccines including all boosters okay I
thought I tried to explain that but
we'll go back in terms of conflict I
think most people are reasonable they
understand that when you go to a health
care setting that's where people are
most at risk your loved one may be at
risk in those settings and health care
workers know that as well so I you know
we have ambassadors who will be there to
make sure you have access to a mask that
you wear it appropriately in those
settings so yes it is a requirement and
yes I do expect that people will comply
with that it's important it's important
as we have more infections in the
community that we do what we need to do
to protect those people who are most at
risk of having severe illness and and
frankly from dying from influenza from
covid from RSV so yes it is important in
the health care settings and I appeal to
our better Natures we know that this is
a a relatively uninvasive unobtrusive
thing that is an important measure in
healthcare settings and I encourage
everybody to to take that point of view
and to make sure that you're doing your
part it protects you and it protects
those around you
our next question is from mirabane
sorry the question in terms of the
healthcare worker mandate so the serial
prevalence tells us we know from data
that most healthcare workers have at
least had at least one booster and also
from the data that most healthcare
workers have hybrid immunity which means
there's a whole combination of different
types of immunity that's out there right
now in our healthcare workers and
everybody who's working in our public
system has that immunity so we know that
any additional requirement is not going
to it's going to be it's not needed for
one thing but it would how do I say this
there's so many different permutations
and combinations that there's no one
single thing that you could do that
would make it work for everybody so we
want to have a period of time between
boosters and infection and the updated
vaccine so there's just too many any
combinations and we know that we have a
high level of Baseline protection for
healthcare workers so the Mandate
remains anybody new to the system must
get this must get vaccinated with this
updated vaccine so if you're
unvaccinated you're coming in through a
job in the Health Care System you get
this updated vaccine and you will be
considered protected as we go into the
this season so it is a combination we
don't go back to zero when we have time
between Doses and we know that we get
boosted from being exposed to the virus
over time
so that's the rationale behind it it is
the data that shows us that there's a
very high level of protection and as
we're going into this season we want to
to ensure that we have added protection
with this updated vaccine
our next question is from Mira Baines
CBC Mara go ahead
thank you this question is uh for Dr
Bonnie Henry uh there was a leaked
provincial memo and it says patients
clients and residents will mask when
directed by a health care worker or
based on personal choice why not mandate
masks for patients in this regard
there's a whole bunch of reasons and
partly because residents in long-term
care that's their home and many people
have issues so we wouldn't expect them
to wear a mask all the time in your home
and for patients in in healthcare
settings if you come in with a
respiratory infection you'll be asked to
put a mask on for sure and we do that
always but there are reasons why people
because of the health reason that
they're seeking care for might not be
able to wear a mask so the Mandate
applies to all the healthcare workers
people working in the facility because
they're the people who are there most
often and and interacting with multiple
people over time as well as visitors and
in terms of residence and and patience
it really is dependent on their own
clinical condition
Mira do you have a follow-up
yes and this is a bit of a longer
question this is a question from a
colleague according to a statement sent
to CBC by your ministry a non-outbreak
circumstance in a hospital or long-term
care home includes when there is an
increased number of covid-19 cases in a
unit or when a variant causes more
severe illness among vaccinated people
what is the rationale for not declaring
an outbreak to inform patients and their
families about these scenarios yeah I
think I'm not sure what that is a
don't know who sent you that statement
but let's be clear around outbreaks and
outbreaks are not just for covet we've
been doing this for a long time we have
outbreaks of influenza RSV right now we
have one I believe it's para influenza
there are a number of viruses that can
cause illness and be transmitted in
healthcare settings and we mostly are
concerned about Long-Term Care Homes
because we know people in those settings
are more likely to have more severe
illness that's why we're focusing
vaccination to make sure that we're
boosting up that immunity for influenza
and for the ones that we do have
vaccines for for covid in Long-Term Care
Homes as a start what we have found in
terms of covet over time is that the
infections are become relatively mild
and so recently we've had a number of
infections in acute care facilities and
as there's more people in the community
with infections there'll be more people
in hospital who bring that infection
with them and in some cases it is a
bunch of people a number of people
who've come into a hospital setting most
likely uh most commonly where they have
covid but it's not because they got it
while they were in hospital or that this
transmission happening within the
facility so sometimes these can be
managed by just taking individual
measures with and making sure those
people who are sick are isolated and not
and wearing masks and making sure we
have what we call additional precautions
on those individuals when we see
transmission within the facility between
people in the hospital in the long-term
care home whatever the virus it is and
we need to take additional measures like
everybody masking all the time
restricting people from communal events
restricting visitors that's when it's an
outbreak and we need to be more
consistent in how we do that it's very
important that we recognize that these
are important for people to know so they
can make a decision about whether
they're going to go in and visit
somebody for example if you're at risk
yourself and for communicating these so
we do have respiratory outbreak and we
call it the Bri environment viral
respiratory infection outbreak manual
that lays out these these
the criteria for when an outbreak is
declared or not there is some discretion
because sometimes we have some mild
illness that's not being transmitted
within Community within a facility where
we don't need to take additional
measures and in those cases it would be
just watching and paying attention to
who's getting sick and and monitoring
and supporting those individuals rather
than having to take
additional measures for the entire unit
or the entire home
our next question is from zaozu
Globe and Mail
um so I'm curious are we paying for RSE
vaccines and uh if so for who and if not
why not thank yeah so the RSV vaccine
there's just been wonderproof there's a
number of others particularly for
children for people who are pregnant
that will protect young infants that are
on the horizon so we're looking forward
to that so the the one vaccine is for uh
people who are 65 years of age and older
and it does show some promising good
protection it's unclear how long that
protection lasts and how many doses
people will need over time it's also
unclear how much will be available in
Canada in the coming months so there's a
couple of things that we're looking at
we don't have a publicly funded program
here in BC at the moment what we're
waiting for are a couple of things
looking at the national advisory
committee on immunization recommending
recommendations for use of this vaccine
as well as looking at the implications
of the use in our Province you know
who's most likely to benefit what
program should we have in place that are
publicly funded or not so all of that is
is underway but we don't yet have a
program in in British Columbia and
likely won't for this season
see how do you have a follow-up
uh
uh uh no thanks
our next question is from Lisa USDA City
News 11 30. Lisa go ahead
hi there Dr Henry just for the masking
who will enforce it and will people be
asked to leave if they refuse to put one
on at a healthcare setting like a
hospital yeah so I hope it doesn't come
to that for most people I think we're
reasonable people and yes masking is
important for those who are visitors in
the hospital
and the ambassadors will be there to
screen people for symptoms to make sure
they have access to masks and we'll be
asking people to wear them we do have
security if needed but I would encourage
people to you know to work with people
and and we don't go to enforcement first
what we go to is is explaining to people
and the importance of doing this making
sure that they're not putting others at
risk and supporting them and being able
to do what we ask them to do
this idea of a follow-up
yes with this round of vaccination I'm
wondering like is there a marker for
what will make it success I remember at
the beginning you know watch the
percentages of people who have it within
BC
um you know 82 82 until we got to the
90s what will be considered the success
this round of vaccinations well it you
know for me and a success is that all of
those people who are most at risk are
protected and those of us who are live
with somebody who's at risk who provide
care to people are also protected so I
would like to see especially increase in
children we know that children don't get
a severe disease mostly but some
children can and we see that in
reflected in the data from the last few
years but particularly the things that
we can do to stop the spread to slow
things down to make sure that we're
doing our best to protect those who are
more vulnerable within our families
within our communities and it protects
our Health Care system so I expect that
people will be anxious I know I'm
hearing a lot from people who are
waiting for this new vaccine because
they don't want to get sick again this
year and this new vaccine works well we
have both products approved for use and
it'll be rolling out in the next few
days
our next question is from Karen McKinley
Grand Forks Gazette Karen go ahead
uh thank you for taking my question I
guess this is more of a question for um
Minister dick uh just going back to
emergency rooms
um uh yeah you say that we're prepared
uh and you have additional beds coming
but uh here especially in Interior
Health we've been dealing with a
rotating emergency room closures and as
we've seen uh every year uh there's a
spike in admittent admissions because of
respiratory illness so uh
this and of course people are concerned
just not just because of this but
because of just in general uh we're
never sure which uh which emergency room
is being closed so just asking how is
this going to help address like the
short-term and long-term uh issues with
the community emergency rooms uh closing
for uh short periods so what addresses
it is action that's why we tripled the
practice ready Assessment program
Community such as Oliver that has had
some issues in recent times against
return of service we make decisions when
we assign people to Oliver and
communities such as Merit and
communities such as Grand Forks so
fundamentally we have to do especially
in rural health is to ensure that we
have the doctors and nurses and nurse
practitioners and now we've of course
got Associate Physicians and Physicians
assistants in different places there to
support people in emergency rooms
secondly we've got to listen to our
communities in in Oliver for example
we've approved a new way of of
remunerating of paying doctors and
sporting doctors which is called an
alternative payment
method which is a move away from what's
called fee for service and that was
developed in working with doctors and so
we're obviously aggressively both in
Grand Forks and in Oliver taking steps
to ensure
that we have a maximum response because
we know how
difficult it is when an emergency room
closure is announced thirdly we have
significant measures across Northern
Health but in other communities for
example Grand Forks has I think access
to every single incentive program that
we have in the province is in Grand
Forks to ensure that we that we build up
both our doctor and nurse capacity in
those communities so and we've created
these provincial networks of nurses and
of doctors to support when when we don't
have enough regular people or people
come away sick are the challenge in the
Health Care system over the last period
and it's just a change and it's not
necessarily a negative change it's just
a change every week in in healthcare we
have between 15 and 16 000 people who
Miss at least one day for illness it's a
huge system there are hundreds of
thousands of people working on it that's
what we have that typically prior to
that pandemic was nine thousand and that
can happen in different ways in
different places so that if you have
people off sick in a community that
depends on a small number of people that
can happen and that's why we're building
up these networks of locums this network
and system of travel nurses to support
communities so what we're seeing is in
every level a massive response and 5 400
5100 sorry more nurses just this year
that's a response we're leading Canada
in the recruitment of nurses the new
doctors that are coming internationally
in the new spaces and medical schools
that's a response the new health health
Allied Health programs and increases in
spaces for Allied Health again and of
course health care assistance and then
expanding the scope of practice of
Health Professions and what we're seeing
is Health Professions working together
as never before more than a hundred
thousand people have received treatment
in Community Pharmacy since we launched
that program in June which I think is a
real success in supporting people and
that helps people get care they need
when they need it so all of these are
the actions we take it's an absolute
priority we do not want to see any
emergency rooms closed and so we're
taking every step in the case of Oliver
which is a community in in your region
for example probably about 50 percent of
the shifts that have been taken in the
last number of months have been Locum
shifts so that is a massive daily effort
by local doctors and by Interior Health
to address that problem similarly in
Grand Forks as we can say the the list
of measures taken and advocated for by
local MLA Russell has been is impressive
so happy to meet with the mayor of Grand
Forks at the ubcm last week to discuss
that and other things we can do to to
improve the situation in the future
because personally we haven't arrived
there yet in Grand Forks there's
relatively relatively few emergency room
closures but we need the hospital to be
open in full and that's that's our goal
and that's our plan
Karen do you have a follow-up
yes and this is more for uh
more for Dr Henry uh just in the of
course in the past pandemic we would
have like super sites and pop-ups for
vaccines uh just considering we've got
uh three vaccines uh coming will there
be any plans for perhaps uh pop-ups or
even like a temporary uh public site
um it's going to be different in
different communities but primarily
vaccines will be available quite widely
in communities through pharmacies both
the covet vaccine and the flu vaccine we
encourage people to get them at the same
time and you'll be able to book the
appointments at the same time in a much
less complicated way than last year so
pharmacists will be the basis of it we
know that that was easily accessible for
people around the province public health
clinics will also be doing pop-ups and
Community clinics in different places to
offer both vaccines and particularly for
children because young children can't
get their vaccines at pharmacies so yes
there's different strategies in
different places as well we know that
there's some family physician offices
and pediatrician offices who will have
vaccines available particularly for
children
our next question is from Victor Kaiser
radio NL Victor go ahead
hi there uh
minutes along the lines of the previous
one to do with Merit I guess the ER
there is currently closed lack of
doctors we understand it's the fourth
closure I believe this month alone uh I
guess Mayor Mike Getz was supposed to
have some kind of a meeting with you
minister at the ubcm to talk about these
these closures wondering if you can shed
light as to what's going on and what's
being done to fix essentially the ER
that's along the coca-halo that's right
and I met with mayor Getz at the ubcn
but he and I regularly talk he says you
know a strong advocate for his community
and we've been working very closely
together I think the the municipality
Merit itself is contributing to this
process by supporting uh some housing
initiatives working with Interior Health
I think they're they're doing a very
good job and we're very appreciative of
that what we're seeing across BC and the
well it was a doctor issue I think in
the present with Merit principally
nurses is the need to continue we've had
said this many times if people
understand we have about 38 000 more
people working for our health care
System than when I started as minister
of Health overwhelmingly
nurses and health science professionals
and healthcare workers but also doctors
we have to of course it's critical that
we be open in the places that people
expect us to be open 24 7 365 and we
need to meet that standard and Merit
that means attracting a larger base of
doctors or nurses so that we're not as
dependent on people coming from other
places so Merit like Grand Forks is the
recipient of numerous incentive programs
to recruit people to the community it
will benefit of course from the practice
ready Assessment program because we'll
be assigning people to Merit who will
come against a return of service for
three years and we're going to continue
to take those actions and you'll recall
because you're in camels you'll recall
the issues we had in the 2022 year when
the discussion was principally around
Clearwater and at that time we did work
on all of these issues including housing
and Recruitment and I believe we've had
maybe perhaps one closure if if that
since Labor Day 2022 so the we're
working hard every day to fill shifts to
make sure that we don't see closures or
they they have them very rarely moment
but the fundamental thing is to have
solutions that mean there are no
closures and that's what we're working
for in Merit and everywhere else
Victor do you have a follow-up
I do and I'm not sure if this is for the
minister or for Dr Henry but uh we're
hearing from a couple of City councilors
here in Kamloops that we're at ubcm that
they and a few others uh have come down
with covet or coveted like symptoms you
don't have to being in one big
delegation or one big Gathering if you
will so I'm not sure if it's something
the province is aware of the bccdc is
looking at a potential super spreadery
type event just for the number of
Municipal politicians that were there
and the number that are now are saying
they're they're unwell
I've just heard that as well from a
number of people who were there and some
of the things I'm hearing about you know
is multiple different uh settings and a
lot of social settings and lots of
people and it just reminds us that there
are viruses out there right now covid
sarsko V2 is one of them in the first
slide I showed there's a bit of green
which is enterovirus and adenovirus and
those also have been spreading and cause
cold flu-like symptoms cough fever
Etc so yes I have heard that there's
some people with covet and others who've
been unwell after coming together during
that week so whether it's an outbreak or
a super spreading event I haven't seen
numbers that would suggest that to me
but we're certainly can look into it and
people can report but importantly what
we're not seeing is large numbers of
more severe illness and that would be
something that would be more worrying I
know some people have been quite sick
but we haven't seen a surge in people
requiring hospital care for example and
I think that's a testament to you know
how many people have been vaccinated and
our our Municipal leaders in particular
and
our last question is from Jennifer Maher
CBC Radio Canada Jennifer go ahead
hello the question is in French Foreign
[Music]
Pharmacy Pharmacy we all see the the
clinic there is foreign
[Music]
hello
it was Emma for the insurance modern
systems
[Music]
preparation processes
um
do you have a follow-up
we you mentioned this a little bit Dr
Henry mentioned it a little bit in
English now in French
foreign
[Music]
a dimetro plus the
um
includes today's event thank you so much